-Welcome back!
-Oh, my goodness. Seth.
-I love to see you, my friend.
-This is a a reunion.
-It is a reunion.
We started together at SNL
and now we find ourselves
later in life.
We each got two children.
Similar ages too, as well.
-Yes. You got boys.
-You got girls, right?
You got a couple.
There's your oldest
with your wife.
Look at how beautiful that is.
-Yes. Yeah.
-And then, I like that the older
one gets a glamour shot,
and then the younger one
just, like --
You just catch what you can.
-You catch what you can when
she's almost looking, you know
-How are they?
-I love it, man.
I love being a dad.
They're great.
If anybody has two sibling
that's close in age
you know the oldest one tries to
not to beat up the youngest one,
of course snatching everything
the oldest one has.
So anything the oldest one has
the baby is like,
"Mine, mine, mine. Me, me, me.
And then every time
she takes it,
the oldest one starts crying
And I'm like, "What are --
You're bigger.
Why are you crying? Push her
down. You know what I'm saying
-Get it back.
-Get it back. Get it back.
-You don't have to ask me
permission for everything.
Step on her toe. We won't know
You know what I mean?
-You went back recently.
I saw you at the SNL 40th.
And then you went back again
for the first time since the
for really one
of the most historic episode
of recent years,
the Eddie Murphy show.
-Eddie Murphy show.
-How was it?
How was it being there?
-Amazing. I was very --
I flew from L.A. I left taping
I said, "I gotta go see Eddie.
And I came out,
and it was everything
I thought it would be.
I thought I would have anxiety
coming back to SNL.
It always feels
like high school.
-Sure.
-But it just felt normal
and great.
And before I knew it,
I just wanted to watch the show.
And Eddie did his thing.
I really came out
to get the photo op.
-You wanted to take a picture.
-I just wanted a picture, man!
-It's hard, though, 'cause
there's not really a place -
It's not like there's a phot
line at the end of the episode
So, how'd it work out?
-At the after-party,
'cause I don't see Eddie.
We're waiting for him
to come out of his dressing room
after the show.
He never comes out.
Everybody's out there. It is
a sea of famous black people
in Studio 8H.
-Yeah.
-It was like
a "Coming to America 2" audition
or something.
It was just everybody famous
that wanted to be in the movie
And so I don't see him there
I get to the party.
I'm sitting there.
Chris Rock kind of, like,
waves over. And I'm like -
I'm thinking he's talking to me.
So I go sit with Chris Rock.
And now we're all hanging ou
and talking, and I'm just like
"Man, I just came out here
to take a picture with Eddie."
He was like,
"Good luck with that."
Eddie walks into the restaurant.
Entourage of 10 people.
And I'm like,
"Yeah, this isn't gonna happen
The only way this could happen
is if he's -- coming...toward...
me...right now."
And his chair was right here
and his table went that wa
while I was on the end
of the table going that way.
And I was like "Eddie!"
He was like --
I was like, "Finesse!"
He was like, "I know, I know
Yeah, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
And then took the pictures
-And we got proof!
There it is! Boom! Look at that!
-There it is. I got my picture
-It's perfect!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Not only just a excellent
sketch player
but one of the best comedian
all time.
-Best comedians of all time.
I will say it was a thrill
to watch him do sketch again
like, just remember, like,
how good he was at that
in a way that nobody's bee
ever since.
-And it just reminded me
of how bad I was
and why I made an early exit
-[ Laughs ] That is not true
I love talking to people,
especially from my era
and their failed sketches.
You had one with Snoop.
-Yes. Yes.
-Who you've run into since
-Yes. Let me tell you why I know
"SNL" sometimes is traumatizin
not only just on the cast
members who is leave the sho
and say, "Oh, this didn't
happen. That didn't happen."
The guests are always
the same way.
Every time -- It's 20 year
later. I see Snoop,
and he's like, "Finesse, why
they didn't do The Apimptice?"
[ Laughter ]
Donald Trump had come
on the show the week before.
We did this big
"Apprentice" sketch.
So, Snoop comes on
the week after,
and he has this grand idea
to do "The Apimptice."
"And instead of saying,
'You're fired,'
I'll just smack a chick
and say, 'You're tired.'"
[ Laughter, groaning ]
And I was like, "Yeah, Snoop
I don't think NBC gonna let yo
smack anybody on TV, so...
-He should be happy now
that they didn't do that.
-That they didn't do it.
[ Laughter ]
-You also had Jermazing.
-Aww.
-Jermazing was a character tha
still holds a place in my heart.
-He had a Jheri curl, people
And every time Jermazing got
excited or you called his name
he says "Huh?"
And his Jheri curl juice
hits the person next to hi
in the face.
-And he was a waiter.
So, imagine saying, "Waiter?
"Huh?"
And juice goes all into Seth's
face or Kristen Wiig's face.
-And it was a lot
of special effects for this,
because they couldn't use --
They couldn't actually
make it work.
So somebody had to, like, spra
juice from the other side.
-Right. Water wasn't
leaving the wig in time.
So they wet a big paintbrush
and just had water on a brush.
And every time I said "Huh?"
they just splash people.
[ Laughter ]
So you just see Kristen Wiig
soaked or Chris Parnell soaked
And when we couldn't
get it right,
they're sitting there all wet,
and they're just looking at me
like, "Your days are numbered.
Your days are numbered."
[ Laughter ]
-You did some Black Histor
Month sketches that I --
-Now, those were --
And it's Black History Month
-Right now.
-Welcome back. Yeah.
-Yes.
Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, Pomerantz,
one of my favorite people.
-Lauren Pomerantz.
-Wonderful writer.
-J.B. Smoove.
-Yeah.
-We came up with Kenny Wilkins
the first black man
to say no to direct deposit.
-Yeah, very famous.
-Yes, very famous sketch.
"So, how do I get my check?"
"Oh, we put it directly
into your bank."
"Yeah, but how do I cash it?
"It is already in your account."
"But how do I know that?"
[ Laughter ]
"You can check your statement.
"One second.
Hell naw!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
-First black man to say no
to sushi.
-Oh, yeah?
Kenny was that, as well. Right
-Yes.
And first black man to say n
to winter sports
that only white people would do.
[ Laughter ]
-Have --
That was a fantastic clip.
Have you been enjoying
"Outmatched?"
This is your
first prime-time sitcom.
-This is my first
prime-time sitcom.
The Lord has really been
blessing people,
and I'm just really excited,
'cause it's a great cast
and great show.
It stars Jason Biggs
from "American Pie."
-There you go.
-Everybody remember Jason Biggs.
-Great seeing him in the clip,
as well.
-Uh-huh.
And Maggie Lawson is his wife.
They have four great kids.
Three are geniuses,
certified geniuses.
And they are not, as parents
They're very not smart.
And one child, the youngest,
is not smart.
So that's the one they lov
the most and identify with
because the other three
are trying to play
"Who's gonna run this house?
-I gotcha.
-And as parents, we all know
kids who hit that age
where they think they're smarter
than the parents.
So, I come over
as the black best friend
and my beautiful wife
Tisha Campbell, who plays Rita
And everybody knows
Tisha Campbell from "Martin"
and "My Wife and Kids."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-And she's a sitcom,
you know, icon.
And it's just a great show, man.
-That's great, man.
-It's fun.
-Congratulations on that.
-I'm just excited about it
-Congratulations on the kids
Always great to see you,
Finesse.
Thank you for being here, buddy.
-Yes.
-Finesse Mitchell.